[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans les
studios du figaro vous êtes en direct
c'est figaro live et on attend vos
points de vue en particulier sur la
perquisition réalisée ce matin notamment
au domicile d'olivier ferrand mais aussi
de l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe d'or siens ministres du
gouvernement agnès buzyn slim et n'diaye
et d'autres responsables hauts
responsables de la santé publique
est ce le bon moment c'est la question
qu'on vous pose et on attend donc vos
points de vue on attend également les
points de vue de lucile schmid bonsoir
lucile ans rappelle que vous êtes ancien
élu ps et ancien élu écologiste
cofondatrice d'ailleurs de la fabrique
écologique et membre du conseil de
rédaction de la revue esprit le dernier
numéro consacre notamment un article sur
la démocratie à l'épreuve de l'épidémie
on posera également la question à
vincent trémolet de villers qui nous
faire confirme bien que la conférence
salle gaveau prévue lundi avec l'avocat
françois sureau est maintenu mais cette
avance dans les tenues elle est avancée
à 18 heures donc françois sureau vient
d'être élu à l'académie française donc
ceux qui viendront auront la chance de
voir un immortel faso et nous avons
décidé de l'avancer à 18 heures pour ne
pas cesser un certain nombre d'éléments
de l'existence qui sont indispensables à
l'hygiène de l'esprit il me semble ça
laissera peut-être le temps d'ailleurs
aux étudiants d'y aller si on l'est si
on les autorise est ce que les jeunes
d'ailleurs son sont particulièrement
irresponsable c'est bien sont-ils
sacrifié sur l'autel de la guerre d âge
c'est l'autre des balles je vous propose
d'avoir ce soir et bien sûr là aussi
j'attends vos points de vue mais d'abord
un gigantesque coup de filet dans la
france entière
jeudi matin ce jeudi matin 80 enquêteurs
de l'office central de lutte contre les
atteintes à l'environnement et à la
santé publique ont déboulé pour une
perquisition polies mais musclées au
domicile de l'actuel ministre de la
santé est également
chez lui à grenoble de l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe des ex membres
du gouvernement agnès buzyn ces bêtes
ndiaye et d'autres perquisitions a été
menée chez le directeur général de la
santé jérôme salomon et à deux lectrices
générale de santé publique france
geneviève chaînes toutes les autres
informations sur cette opération sont à
retrouver dans un article qu on va vous
mettre dans le chatt signé paul gonzalez
moi je vous propose d'écouter les
explications de l'avocat des plaignants
fabrice di vizio c'était ce midi au
micro de ses news les clients veulent
c'est la vérité la vérité sur quoi la
vérité sur l'étendue et la pertinence
des déclarations faites par madame buse
si madame busin n'avait pas fait les
déclarations qu'elle a faites
peut-être que de plainte il n'y aurait
jamais eu que l'élément déclencheur
c'est pas la gestion de l'épidémie
c'est le fait que madame buza est
déclaré qu'elle savait avant tout le
monde qu'elle a envoyé des mails et qu'
elle savait le tsunami qui allait
s'abattre devant nous tandis que si
l'épidémie venait à se déclencher en
tout cas se propager il faudrait annuler
les municipales
elle a dit à philippe juvin au mois de
janvier que tout était prêt s'agissant
des masques
or on sait aujourd'hui que c'est pas
prêt et le moins que l'on puisse faire
c'est d'avoir des éléments objectifs
dans quai
alors des éléments d'objectif en
attendant ces éléments d'objectifs
denquête on attendait la réaction
d'olivier vais rentrer dans qui était en
conférence de presse cet après midi il
n'a pas réagi sur la question c'est le
premier ministre lui-même visé par une
plainte mais il n'y a pas eu de
perquisition pour l'instant chez lui qui
a volé à son secours on avait parlé
d'ailleurs dans ce plateau vincent de la
plainte qui visait jean castex donc pas
d'allusion la de jean castex à cette
plainte qui le vise
mais il a volé au secours du ministre de
la santé oms l'écoutent vous comprendrez
tout et tout ce qu'il ne m'appartient
absolument pas de commenter des
décisions d'une autorité judiciaire
absolument pas avant je peux tout à fait
répondre à votre deuxième question sur
la confiance que j'accorde à monsieur
olivier verront ici présents sachez
qu'elle est totale outre bien entendu
elle besoin de rappeler que sur le volet
judiciaire que je ne connais pas il
bénéficie d'une totale présomption
d'innocence une totale présomption
d'innocence à 100 est-ce qu'on c est
pourquoi aujourd'hui est ce que c'est un
hasard du calendrier et d'ailleurs est
ce qu'on sait si les intéressés ont été
surpris je crois que si on en croit
l'article de paul gonzalez qui toujours
très renseignés ils ont peu été
surprises ont été stupéfaits ils ont été
stupéfaits parce que ces perquisitions
sont quand même très spectaculaire et
que pour le moment c'est plein
d'avancées mais on n'en avait pas on
n'avait pas connaissance de cet
événement là alors ensuite il ya la
question des deux agendas qui se
rejoignent un agenda sanitaire de là
la conférence de presse et l'agenda
judiciaire alors c'est toujours très
compliqué de savoir si les choses
seraient penser de façon chronologique
parce qu'une perquisition ça se décide
pas la veille au soir il ya des éléments
qui est qui qui oblige à la décidée
avant donc on savait pas qu'il y avait
la déclaration de macron donc je pense
que le le le
la conjonction des dates se joue à une
semaine à quinze jours mais à 24 heures
ça me paraît impensable après sur le
fond là je vois que je trouve qu'on
touche un très grave problème de du lien
entre police entre la politique et la
justice c'est que cette justice en
surplomb je pense est un des éléments
non dits de l'inertie ou de la très
grande prudence sur notre très grande
précaution des pouvoirs publics depuis
le début de cette histoire est que ils
choisissent ils décident en fonction du
bien commun mais aussi en fonction de la
contrainte judiciaire parce que les
plaintes sont possibles elles sont
légitimes on peut les discuter
moralement on peut considérer que quand
on est assez affronte une épidémie a
autre chose à faire que de le soupçonner
mais on peut en droit exigé de savoir
mais on voit que chacun gère finalement
son risque pénal autant qu'ils le qu'il
s'occupe de la chose publique et je
pense que ceci n'est pas ça il ya une
chose alors lui n'est pas n'est pas
menacé par le risque pénal mais plus par
les cours détaillé constitution d'un
conseil d'état et conseil
constitutionnel qui pourrait invalider
hassan homme de décision mais hier
emmanuel macron a répété je sais pas
combien de fois j'ai pas compté mais
peut-être plus de 10 fois le mot
proportionnée disproportionnée qui sont
les termes employés pour juger de la
légitimité ou non d'une décision et donc
on voit il est sain que le droit est
toute sa part dans une décision
politique
il me paraît en tout cas là on voit
vraiment l'effet délétère d'une
puissance publique tétanisés à l'idée de
devoir être embarqué dans des procédures
qui peuvent durer des années et qui
peuvent à la fin aboutir à rien du tout
des effets délétères d'une puissance
publique tétanisés par par ces
procédures ne dit vincent
un internaute que challes une crise
interne fidèles de figure là ils nous
disent vous c'est une vengeance des
magistrats contre dupond-moretti ce je
ne sais pas on en discutera peut-être
mais par contre ce que révèle paul
gonzalez également c'est que eric dupond
moretti
visiblement n'a pas été mis au courant
de la perspective de cette perquisition
il faut s'en réjouir c'est là c'est
l'indépendance des juges de lui s'il
sait pas s'il faut s'en réjouir mais je
pense qu'il valait mieux pour eric
dupond moretti qui ne soit pas au
courant parce que s'il avait été au
courant
il devait ne pas en parler aux
intéressés au nom du principe
d'indépendance et donc ça lui aurait
sans doute posé un tas de conscience moi
je pense que pour répondre ou réagir par
rapport à ce que disait vincent
je pense que ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'au départ on a 90 plaintes et
qui ne finit il reste moins de 10 donc
il ya eu déjà un premier filtre assez
important qui a été fait donc c'est une
plainte sur dix est donc les plaintes
qui sont retenus c'est des plaintes
notamment posé par des familles de
victimes mais surtout par des collectifs
de médecins et de soignants c'est à dire
que il ya évidemment un an leur section
c class action et c'est surtout toute
cette question des masques en fait c'est
à dire que c'est la question de ne pas
avoir eu le matériel pour se protéger
est ce que c'est c'est au fond nous
avoir condamné à mort puisqu'il ya un
certain nombre de personnels soignants
qui sont décédés du co lead en soignant
des malades du code vide
donc je pense que c'est une vraie
question et comme l'a rappelé l'avocat
enfin l'un des avocats des personnes qui
portent plainte
c'est vrai que l'interview l'interview
d'agnès busin dans le monde après le
premier tour des municipales et quelques
jeux de mots l'interview de propos
rapportés d'ailleurs enfin je pense
qu'elle les a pas vraiment faim les a
pas ouvertement rester à lézat bras elle
elle les a pas démentis les a pas
contesté en justice donc me semble-t-il
les a en fait entériner de fait en tout
cas ce qu'elle dit dans cette interview
je peux le rappeler c'est quand même que
l'organisation du premier tour des
élections municipales était une
mascarade et qu'elle savait depuis
janvier qu'il ne fallait pas le faire
donc c'est vrai que ça vient directement
du coeur du pouvoir d'avoir alimenté la
suspicion et c'est sans doute pour cette
raison d'ailleurs que il a été jugé que
cette plainte était recevable
à mon sens il avait pas eu l'entretien
ou les propos rapportés d'agnès b d'un
poids de précise presque juridiquement
je crois que c'est plein de n'aurait pas
été jugées fondées
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est qu'on a en même temps un exercice
parlementaire où il ya des commissions d
enquête et rappelez vous qu emmanuel
macron alors que les commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires se sont
constitués avait aussi souhaité
organiser sa propre commission denquête
donc on est dans une situation où
quasiment on déroule alors même que nous
sommes encore dans l'épidémie de kovy d'
une espèce de banquettes en live alors
qu'on est en train de vivre un deuxième
épisode
moi je m'interroge là dessus aussi sur
le fait que qui que se passe-t-il autour
de cette espèce de cacophonie denquête
entre le judiciaire donc comme vous le
disiez l'infraction pénale
la taxe sur certaines personnes c'est à
dire que c'est quand même des questions
personnelles en fonction de la fonction
du côté parlementaire c'est le système
qui est attaquée ou qui doit être évalué
et puis il ya emmanuel macron qui veut
voir si au fond il il aurait pu faire
mieux
donc tout ça fait beaucoup pour les
citoyens et dans un moment où il ya une
crise de confiance très forte à l'égard
du pouvoir
évidemment ça va alimenter en tous les
cas un profond scepticisme c'est dans le
dans le chatt actuelle du figaro
notamment nicole qui nous dit ça se
terminera comme pour le sang contaminé
le médiateur le levothyrox et cetera
responsable mais pas coupable mais le
faut rappeler justement que le sang
contaminé
j'ai plus en tête le mais je crois que
ces dix ans dix ans pendant lesquels
laurent fabius est poursuivi par par
cette affaire et c'est ça que beaucoup
de responsables politiques ont en tête
et c'est en fonction aussi de cet
élément là c'est pas c'est l'unique
élément c'est une des contraintes dans
leur esprit qu'ils prennent leurs
décisions là c'est vrai qu'il ya un
élément veux qu'ils qui est objectif et
qui est manifeste c'est que le dossier
de l'instruction été nourrie par un des
protagonistes de cette histoire c'est à
dire que là je rejoins absolument ce que
des 10800 l'article
dans le monde dans lequel agnès buzyn
confié avoir envoyé un mail fin janvier
à edouard philippe
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de plaintes
recevables et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
disait l'avocat que nous avons entendu
là il ya un élément concret et tangible
avec une trace écrite qui est de dire on
savait et nous n'avons pas fait en gros
c'est ça qu'elle qu'elle explique donc
c'est pas le camp des opposants qui
vient contrarier ou lancer cette
procédure s'est lancé le ministre de la
santé elle-même donc la cci
c'est cet objectif alors après moi je
trouve regrettable
encore une fois j'ai revient alors pour
le moment la constitution le permet et
il est tout à fait légitime que des
groupes puissent porter plainte et que
la responsabilité d'un politique ne soit
pas seulement politique mais ça a aussi
apprécié vous trouvez ça c'est la loi
c'est la loi c'est donc quoi c'est le
droit c'est le droit mais je trouve
qu'il ya dans ce fonctionnement
quelque chose qui qui pour le coup ne
et oblique qui est des qui est dévoyée
et peut-être faudrait-il c'est une piste
être extraordinairement sévère avec les
plaintes irrecevables les plaintes
abusives pour empêcher les cabinets
d'avocats et les associations d'utiliser
le droit à des fins simplement
d'agitation médiatique et pour ternir
des réputations parce que pour les gens
perquisition qu'est ce que ça veut dire
lorsque ça veut dire ça les mots sont
extrêmement forts et à l'arrivée des
personnalités sont abîmés donc peut-être
qu'il faudrait au moins renforcer cela
sinon on va arriver à un fonctionnement
un peu à l'américaine où un bon cabinet
d'avocats un peu performant avec des
relais médiatiques un peu efficace peut
installer une affaire dans dans l'espace
public sans qu'il y ait un dossier
finalement très très nourris mais moi ce
que je pense c'est que cette question
des délais sa direction la sphère du
sang contaminé et effectivement elle est
de plus en plus souvent cités il est
clair que les délais ont été beaucoup
trop long et que la question de la
responsabilité politique n'a pas été
éclaircies en plus ça fait quand même
beaucoup
donc là le sujet c'est à la fois d'aller
sans doute beaucoup plus vite
ensuite j'aurai quand même rappeler que
les décisions de justice
elles sont motivées c'est à dire que il
est essentiel par exemple que si on
décide qu'il n'y a pas d'infraction
pénale pour l'ensemble des personnes qui
ont été dont sur lesquels il ya plainte
il est essentiel que les choses soient
motivés il est essentiel que les
éléments factuels soit exposé et ça
signifie ça illustre en fait ce qui se
passe le défaut de communication le
défaut de fait le défaut de débats en
fait sur ce qui s'est passé autour de la
première vague et le sentiment que le
pouvoir en plus en place le gouvernement
peut se retourner d'un jour à l'autre
autour de la question des masses mme
donc il ya quelque chose qui est
illustratif
je ne vais pas dire que c'est une chance
ces plaintes mais en tout cas maintenant
qu'elles ont été jugés recevables
ça doit être en quelque sorte fait de la
manière la plus juridique possible et le
plus rapidement possible puisque en font
ce qui se passe par rapport à l' affaire
du sang contaminé sait aussi que le
temps politique et le temps du dialogue
entre citoyens et les gouvernements est
un temps extraordinairement marqué par
l'urgence et qu'en plus on est dans une
deuxième vague et qu'il faut restaurer
le sentiment que ça fonctionne mieux au
moment de la deuxième vague
vous pensez que justement ça peut être
une opportunité cette plainte
ou bien est-ce que ça peut être surtout
un moyen
de mettre en scène certains certains
jugent certaines procédures et de
débattre sur ses adversaires mais il
faut un peu se mettre dans la tête ou
l'état d'esprit d'oliver rend ce matin
qui doit tenir une conférence de presse
à 14h et qui est perquisitionné chez lui
dans ses deux domiciles
je sais pas si c'est en tout cas pour le
pouvoir en place et pour la stratégie de
lutte contre l'épidémie
ce n'est pas une opportunité parce que
ça vient rappeler les échecs passés hors
tout le travail qui est fait dans la
communication gouvernementale ils soient
de nier ces échecs soin de dire qu'ils
sont tellement lointain et qui sont le
fait d'une découverte d'un phénomène que
personne ne connaissait ce qui est vrai
que ça sert à rien d'y revenir et la
salle et restaure au coeur de
l'actualité et des esprits et c'est vrai
que le dossier n'est pas vide parce que
l'histoire des masques et cette espèce
d'obsession et olivier ferrand il ya
participé très très longtemps les angles
saad alami l'utilité des lilas même 17
pouvait être dangereux et ensuite il a
nié le le le fait qu'ils aient dit le
coup le pouvoir en place avait pratiqué
un pieux mensonge c'est à dire compte
tenu de la pénurie de masques pour pas
qu'ils aient d'inquiétude ou une rupture
des meutes de gens voulant s'en procurer
on a expliqué que ça servait à rien d'en
avoir un parti on était soigné en bon
c'était peut-être un pur mensonge est
légitime encore une fois dans la
décision politique on aime moi j'étais
pas leur place donc c'était quand même
extraordinairement compliquée mais à
l'arrivée pour un esprit sensé
c'est ce double discours est à peu près
indéfendable au fait il n'y a pas juste
très rapidement mais si y'a pas aussi
est tout simplement une incapacité
lorsqu'on est au pouvoir lorsqu'on est
dans un gouvernement
dire je me suis trompé certes c'est même
pas un double langage c'est le sentiment
qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'on s'est
trompé alors que tout le monde le sait
et là c'est presque une attitude
infantile c'est comme l'enfant non voilà
il ya un moment il faut dire je me suis
trompé et je pense oui mais là on
revient lui ça il à l'ombre de la
justice en surplomb c'est en écoutant
jean castex tout à l'heure à 14h30 il a
commencé sa conférence de presse il ya
eu un long préalable sur ce qu'il avait
fait depuis qu'il est arrivé à matignon
et on pouvait lire cette déclaration
avec à l'esprit les perquisitions du
matin comme une espèce de deux pièces
apportées au dossier de l'efficacité et
de la haie de la véracité de ce qu'il a
pu faire et c'est pas ça pour le moment
le problème c'est pas ça qui devrait
préoccuper et jean castex et ceux qui
l'écoutent d'un mot on pose d'ailleurs
la question sur twitter approuvez-vous
les plaintes déposées à l'encontre des
responsables politiques
il ya une large majorité qui répondent
oui on va le voir dans un instant aux
alentours de 60 3%
on va regarder également l'extrait du
sondage au doxa pour le figaro et france
info apparaître dans les prochaines
heures
on voit que les français approuvent en
majorité les mesures du couvre-feu 64 64
% avec en plus 64% également dans les
zones qui sont visés pas l'ile-de-france
et les huit autres métropoles
vincent est ce que l'opinion justement
peut approuver ces perquisitions est ce
que ça peut satisfaire ce que philippe
muray appelé le désir de pénal
l opinion des queues
un politique est mal en point enfin une
partie de l'opinion considère qu'elle
tient sa vengeance
donc oui enfin ça m'étonne pas que dans
les sondages l'opinion se disent que
untel ou untel qui est en difficulté
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'il faut
des il faut des des boucs émissaires et
le jeu de l'opinion dans cette histoire
et est intéressant parce que l'état je
pense suit l'opinion plus qu'il ne
voudrait la modeler c'est à dire que
l'opinion est inquiète
elle peut être contradictoires et elle
demande à l'état de ne jamais se tromper
et donc l'état des réactions que moi je
trouve excessive et comme celle qui
aurait été prise hier par emmanuel
macron est en fait ce qui est frappant
c'est que ce qui est excessif il me
semble dans ses décisions
c'est qu'elle ébranle la démocratie
libérale et les libertés publiques et
c'est une chose qui n'est pas invoquer
ni dans les débats politiques ni dans
les sondages d'opinion c'est à dire
qu'on a l'impression que la décision la
plus autoritaire satisfait un très grand
nombre de gens qui en mal d'autorité se
disent ont de toute façon maintenant on
aimerait que ce soit tenue donc bon nous
dit couvre feu va très bien ça veut dire
qu'il ya un mois il ya un acte
d'autorité qui est posée je pense que la
question de la liberté tout à fait
minoritaire mais qu'elle doit être
défendue d'autant plus parce qu'elle est
centrale dans notre histoire et dans
notre organisation sociale
oui moi ce que je trouve c'est que par
rapport à ce qui se passe il ya aussi
une vraie injustice sur la temporalité
alors je voyais que il y aura aussi il
ya des plaintes qui ont été déposées
sont en train d'être instruite par
rapport au service parce que quand on
dit l'état il ya une différence entre
les services de l'état
et puis le gouvernement et les ministres
c'est à dire qu'on sait bien que la
question des masques elle n'a pas
commencé au temps où emmanuel macron a
été élu président de la république
donc il ya un vrai sujet sur la façon
dont depuis des années on a été
fortement documenté l'hôpital voilà donc
on a on a un sujet aussi sur la
continuité des erreurs par rapport à
l'hôpital par rapport aux masques moi je
pense que le fait de ne pas avoir
associé les médecins généralistes
suffisamment et les soignants qui sont
en ville qui sont au premier contact
avec les gens du cowitz a inspiré des
plaintes
et donc à partir de là le problème de
l'infraction pénale
lorsqu'on cherche un bouc émissaire
c'est que ça ne permet pas de rendre
vraiment justice et moi à partir de ce
sentiment je pense que le sujet serait
ainsi cela dessus des commissions
parlementaires si elles peuvent
travailler en toute indépendance il se
trouve que le parlement aujourd'hui
environ
montre moi je sais je sais pas si on a
l'impression que c'est flou temps non
mais c'est très flottant mais la vérité
la vérité voilà il ya des choses
intéressantes la vérité c'est que c'est
le moment ou jamais pour nos
parlementaires de montrer qu'ils
représentent un vrai contre-pouvoir dans
une période où les libertés publiques
sont restreintes
donc il ya une opportunité moi je crois
plus en tout cas à ce type d'exercice
car l'infraction pénale lui si vous
entendrez les réactions des oppositions
qu'elle soit de gauche ou de droite
elles se font sur les décisions 10 ans
est passé où c'est trop jeune dans
sanitaires il n'y a pas assez d'argent
nous ne pouvons trop pour le le les plus
humbles mais la question des libertés
publiques et par exemple du fait qu'un
seul homme puisse décider de fermer huit
villes à 21h elle et j'ai vu philippe
bas simplement donc au coc nadir on peut
dire on ne peut pas ne pas en débattre
au parlement
mais sinon elle est très très rarement
invoquée et ça me semble préoccupant on
a peut-être avec françois sureau salle
gaveau juste sur l'opinion je vous
précise deux choses d'abord dans le
tchat
il y avait un autre sentiment qu'ils
étaient exprimées à l'encontre des juges
notamment une défiance à l'égard à
l'égard des juges et peut-être mais
avant je vous demande d'être court kriss
kross qui nous dit philippe peut dire
adieu à 2022 et il en a au moins
jusqu'en 2032
non ce jeu
très difficile d'en juger il faudrait
que la procédure aille à son terme qu'il
y ait une mise en examen
tout ça peut être réglé dans un an et
puis chacun peut être blanchi donc chris
krause nous sommes un peu présomptueux
dans ses pronostics non moi je pense que
edward filet de la popularité des grands
philips elle est aussi stable
aujourd'hui c'est justement parce qu'ils
donnent le sentiment d'avoir été un
point de référence pendant la crise donc
je pense que ça peut pas le déstabiliser
quand même les perquisitions de troie
parce que je crois qu'on découvre en
plus il est à edouard polyp est pas du
tout à cela non pas du tout on la voyait
pas de déclarations dans lesquelles ils
ont cessé de voir en de salomon agnès
buzyn et ensuite olivier ferrand et non
parce que sur les privations de liberté
encore une fois il peut être parfois il
en faut mais edouard philippe quand il
est présenté
avant de dire qu'il devait prendre ces
décisions là il l'expliquait comme ça
lui était pénible on n'a pas entendu ça
dans la bouche de jean castex ou
tailleur ni même dans celles d' emmanuel
macron qui n'avait pas ce que les
romains appelaient hier soir apple a
gravi tu as qui auraient dû normalement
exister dans une déclaration aussi
importante que celle de l'installation
d'un couvre-feu qu'on n'a pas vue depuis
or les émeutes de 2005 depuis la guerre
d'algérie et c'était son ton était et
est assez léger finalement par rapport à
la gravité du moment ont donc on vous
posait la question assure justement là
l'ehpad avril le couvre-feu ça vous avez
les questions qui sont posées sur le
site du figaro vous découvrirez donc le
sondage audois que ça pour figaro france
info dans les prochaines heures sur le
site du figaro et dans l'édition papier
du figaro daté de demain
approuvez-vous les plaintes déposées à
l'encontre des responsables politiques
ça c'est la question qu'ont posé sur
twitter et vous répondez largement oui à
63%
il ya une autre question qu'on pose sur
twitter c'est la jeunesse de 2020 et
elle doit elle être plus responsable à
face à la crise sanitaire
elle est dans le collimateur dans le
viseur a commencé du premier ministre
cet après midi on écoute toutes les
fêtes privées comme les mariages ou les
soirées étudiantes qui se tiennent dans
des salles des fêtes dans des salles
polyvalentes ou tout autre établissement
recevant du public seront interdites
donc plus de fête étudiante la jeunesse
donc de 2020 d'hôtel plus de talent être
plus responsables face à la crise
sanitaire je rappelle que c'est la
question qu'on pose sur les tweets sur
twitter et pour vous aider à répondre je
vous propose d'écouter de point de vue
d'abord celui du chef de l'état hier
dans ce fameux interview accordée à
gilles bouleau et anne sophie lapix
c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2020
c'est dur donc je donnerais jamais de
leçon à nos jeunes est ce que ce sont
ceux qui honnêtement vivent un sacrifice
terrible des examens annulé de l'
angoisse pour les formations de l'
angoisse pour trouver le premier job
mais c'est normal quand on est jeune on
fait la fête on a des amis et donc je
culpabiliserai personnes
alors martine aubry elle a moins de
scrupules je vous propose d'écouter
c'était il ya quelques jours
la maire socialiste de lille a mais moi
j'en appelle à la responsabilité déjà
aujourd'hui vous êtes peu touchées même
s'il ya des cas graves aussi chez les
jeunes
pensez à vos familles pensez à la
société quand on est jeune on prépare
son avenir
laissez les autres aussi avoir cet
avenir donc j'espère que les passages à
des mesures plus drastiques les
amèneront effectivement arrive
à être plus responsables c'était ça la
fin du la phrase vous partager le point
de vue de la dame des 35 heures missiles
d'abord pour moi la dame des 35 heures
ça peut être un compliment et ensuite
par rapport à par rapport à cette
question deux des jeunes de nos jeunes
comme dit le président la république ce
que je trouve extraordinairement
paternaliste c'est dire que moi je veux
je pense que j'ai d'abord en face de moi
des personnes je passe pas mon temps à
me dire quel âge at il et la question
que je me pose c'est quand même pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne dit pas
meyer mc on l'a un peu esquissé mais
peut-être martine aubry aurait pu y
penser c'est parce qu'ils sont
complètement sacrifiés par le climat de
récession économique c'est-à-dire
trouver un premier emploi tout
simplement avoir un job d'étudiant pour
financer ses études
enfin le réduire un étudiant au fait
qu'il fasse la fête alors que il est en
train de passer des examens il est en
train sans doute de préparer son avenir
un peu plus que nous je crois que ça
c'est des choses qui doivent être dites
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que moi ou pas martine aubry ah
bah non
enfin je partage le fait qu'elle en
appelle à la responsabilité collective
c'est à dire qu'il ya quelque chose de
pas d'accord responsabilité collective à
la responsable
alors elle a utilisé au moins deux ou
trois fois en une minute et demie le
terme de responsabilité
et ça je pense que c'est une vraie
question c'est à dire arrêtez de nous
infantiliser qu'on soit jeune ou pas est
un enjeu et notamment si on veut
articuler la question des libertés la
sécurité la deuxième chose c'est je
trouve que cet amalgame sur les jeunes
les jeunes moi c'est un truc qui me gêne
profondément c'est à dire que il faut
discuter avec des personnes qui sont
justement responsables et prendre en
considération le fait que pour eux la
vie plus difficile sur le plan financier
la question du logement la question de
ce pouvoir s'alimenter la montée de la
précarité ça a été montré par
différentes associations que ce soit le
secours populaire
que ce soit les associations de lutte
contre la précarité les jeunes sont
parmi les premiers touchés donc pas sa
séquelle que ce discours anti jeunes
franchement il me révolte ça y est
est-ce que c'est pas un peu démago de se
dit révolté par le discours anti ben oui
enfin je raisonne pas en me disant que
ce que serena dame démago pas démago il
se trouve que j'entends depuis
maintenant un mois et demi un certain
nombre de personnes faire la leçon à la
jeunesse en disant qu'elle se comporte
mal parfois ces personnes sont membres
d'une génération qui a considéré que
toutes interdites et et était une
contrainte insupportable et 68 je sais
pas je veux pas dire que c'est pas
demain la veille à 168 c'est encore
peut-être la génération d'autres su mais
enfin des gens qui se sont affranchis de
toutes les règles en se disant qu'ils
pouvaient profiter de l'existence et qui
désormais 10 aux jeunes alors qu'on est
le dise
que ces jeunes dans leur grande majorité
ne risque rien qui fait beau qui n'ont
pas pu faire leur tour d'europe qui
rêvait de faire avec leurs billets de
train pas cher d'arrêter de vouloir
danser dans la rue je trouve ça
absolument insensé ensuite il faut quand
même mesuré que les jeunes qui n'ont pas
la chance d'avoir des liens sociaux
établis soit par la famille soit par des
amitiés ou une organisation locale très
fortes peuvent se retrouver aujourd'hui
dans une situation d'isolement qui est
aussi terrible que celle de leurs grands
aînés c'est à dire que voir des
étudiants qui ont une chambre
d'étudiants qui n'ont pas cours
donc ils regardent leurs cours sur leur
ordinateur qui le soir ne vous pourrez
pouvoir aller boire un coup avec leurs
amis qui n'ont pas de vie associative
qui n'ont pas de vie sportive qui ont
une ville culturelle réduite au plus
limité mais c'est épouvantable on se
croirait dans le pire des romans de
houellebecq
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'ils qui suivent leur cours ben je
sais pas mais il roulait particules
éléments et puis ça laissait son roman
les particules élémentaires ou le seul
moment de bonheur du héros c'est quand
il ya la semaine italienne chez
carrefour et la burrata est moins cher
bon sens
à l'avant et c'est quand même quelques
et est donc ça veut dire quoi
j'en parlais avec un jeune que je
connais bien puisque c'est mon fils il
dit donc ça veut dire on regarde nos
cours sur notre écran puis ensuite on
travaille dans notre chambre qui apprend
aux commandes un über 800 regardant une
série sur netflix et sa l'existence que
qui ne sait pas c'est pas exagérer après
ils ont leurs perspectives
professionnelles quand ils ont eu des
diplômes quand ils ont eu des contrats
pros qui sont parfois arrêtés il avait
un contrat pro en juin
donc on leur dit que ça ne marche pas
aujourd'hui
et enfin il faut quand même que ceux qui
les mettent en accusation comprennent
que pour eux si jamais il y avait un
risque médical est vital très important
dans leur vie concrète il a pris créer
des règles de façon beaucoup plus
évidente
donc ils se sentent souvent étranger à
ce qu'on leur raconte
et on ne baisse pas laurent benoit est
ce que c'est pas ça justement qu'on leur
qu'on leur reproche
et que cette génération qui a précédé
leur reproche d'être jeune et d'être
étranger au problème
et puis il ya peut-être une forme de
jalousie c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi le
fait qu'effectivement ils risquent mois
leur vie que des personnes plus âgées
n'ont pas de nom pas de trucs de
cobourne morbidité et c'est donc il faut
arrêter cette espèce de truc anti jeunes
qui quelque part recouvre aussi nos
propres pour couvrir les angoisses de
certains mois la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire c'est quand même que par
rapport à ces personnes que l'on côtoie
qui sont plus jeunes que nous que soient
nos enfants les amis nos enfants ou des
jeunes qu'on rencontre dans le cadre
professionnel
moi je trouve qu'ils ont des vraies
inquiétudes par rapport à leurs parents
leurs grands parents leurs proches etc
c'est à dire que c'est ce que j'ai
d'ailleurs alex henry les jeunes sont
sept sur twitter où l'on pose la
question sur la réponse qu'il fait les
jeunes sont déjà responsables
on ne fait entre nous on ne fait pas
particulièrement attention il est vrai
car il n'y a aucun risque mais quand on
côtoie des personnes vulnérables on met
le masque et garde les distances pour
les épargnes à saïfi est par ailleurs on
s'inquiète aussi peut-être parce que
d'une certaine manière au fur à mesure
que les profils sont mieux connus de
ceux qui risquent gros
par rapport aux qu'ovide les choses
aussi on voit par rapport à ses proches
et quand on est jeune comme quand on est
moins jeunes
il ya des personnes auxquelles on tient
et ça c'est quelque chose que je ressens
assez fortement
l'inquiétude que ressentent des gens
même pour moi qui sont plus jeunes que
moi même jamais fait attention et c'est
quelquefois d'ailleurs on a besoin vous
savez qu'on nous dise de faire attention
parce que notre génération à ma
génération peut aussi se sentir et
mortelle contre toutes les statistiques
donc s'imaginer qu'il ya qu' une
personne de 20 ans qui sera
irrationnelle c'est totalement faux moi
je vois aussi des personnes qui sont
fondés personnes à risque qui n'ont pas
envie de le reconnaître parce que tout
simplement on n'a pas envie de justement
contrainte ça nous libère des nouvelles
pense que là on touche à quelque chose
d'extrêmement profond et c'est peut-être
sur le plan anthropologique mais ce
qu'il ya de plus terrible dans cette
histoire c'est que des règles et des
doctrines sanitaires viennent s'insérer
dans les liens les plus établies les
plus simples de la vie humaine et on en
arrive à des excès qui sont les suivants
c'est un témoignage qu'on m'a rapporté
d'un enfant de 10 ans qui dix ans à sa
mère parce qu'on voit si on va voir ma
grand mère j'ai peur puisque je vais la
tuer parce qu'il avait vu un spot à la
télévision et qu'il n'avait pas bon et
quand ton canton comme ça veut dire
ondraise ont commencé à dresser les
petits enfants contre les grands parents
les parents contre les enfants
et là il ya dans la parole publique et
gouvernementales et certains
scientifiques ou médecins sur des
plateaux qui est à mon avis absolument
irresponsable parce que quand une
personne un grand père de 75 ans voit
son petit fils de 10 ans il sait ce
qu'il fait il a pas besoin d'entendre
les recommandations du premier ministre
du ministre de la santé qui doit enfin
nous à dire quand il fallait ouvrir les
fenêtres et combien va émettre à cette
attaque dont tout est possible mais mais
mais il sait ce qui fait donc non mais
là je crois je crois véritablement que
d'ailleurs robert et des call of une
belle tribune chez nous dans ce matin le
les liens sociaux les plus évidents et
les ceux dont on pouvait penser qu'ils
seraient fragilisés par rien sont
atteints par par ce virus
et je crois que c'est l'un des effets
les plus est plus triste au fait de
cette histoire
nicole qui signait souvenirs sont bons
vous corrigez nicole mais je pense que
vous êtes justement plutôt de l'âge des
grands-parents et vous dites je trouve
inadmissible de dire aux enfants qu'ils
risquent de contaminer leurs grands
parents
c'est ce que j'ai vu à midi dans un
reportage méditel david sur twitter
qu'il faut bien que jeunesse se passe
on a fait des trucs idiots ou débile
dans leur jeunesse mais là on n'est pas
forcément question la jeunesse nous 17 m
elle doit aller à l'école pour faire
tourner le monde de demain vous croyez
que si le fait de se retrouver dans un
bar qui pose problème et âme qui nous
dit également les sons laissez nous
vivre inverse il ya tic série dia qui
dit un type de 40 ans célibataire il a
le même quotidien qu'un jeune de 20 ans
télétravail etc
bah oui mais s'est dit la raison et
quand emmanuel macron dit quand on est
jeune on a des amis et on fait la fête
mais c'est pas que quand on est jeune
c'est cette phrase veut absolument rien
dire quand on quand on est quand on aime
la vie on a des amis et on retrouve ses
amis pour des moments de converger à
dire que la phrase pardon mais la phrase
d'emmanuel vaincrons quand on est jeune
on a envie de vous le dire mais c'est
quoi ton est belle oui je serai pas dire
c'est quoi ces 18 45 dans ce cas là dont
on est
on a des enfants des proches des liens
enfin plusieurs jeunes qui déteste les
soirées il y en a deux et les catégories
sociologiques la genèse dernier point
les associations étudiantes et les
syndicats étudiants je trouve sont assez
discret dans cette dans cette affaire
est ce que je me trompe je vais quand
même fait un tour sur leurs réseaux
sociaux j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
protestation par rapport à ces mesures
un bain j'avoue que j'ai pas étudier de
près la question ce qui est vrai c'est
que pour le moment
pour le coup on a interrogé des
sociologues là dessus et notamment des
socios le conte travailler sur ce qu'on
appelle la guerre des âges où les
problèmes intergénérationnels
pour le moment ne se dessine pas une
défiance dans la jeunesse vis-à-vis des
autres générations
moi je crois qu'il faut faire attention
quand même parce que c'est des choses
qui peuvent venir assez vite
hélas le fait de notamment du couvre-feu
et de l'empêchement d'une vie sociale
pour 21h c'est pas la même chose pour le
coup je pense à 55 ans de tuer soit 21h
kaka 19 va entraîner pas mal de pas mal
de ressentiment mais il ya aussi une
chose qu'on dit pas assez c'est à dire
que le principal sujet pour la jeunesse
c'est l'accès à l'emploi ils accès à
l'émancipation économique c'est à dire
qu'est ce que cette crise va permettre
par exemple de d'embaucher les jeunes
parce que ce qui a été demandé c'est par
exemple qu'ils soient payés au premier
au premier jour de stage ou des choses
comme ça est-ce que ça va pas être l'
inverse c'est-à-dire qu'elles aient des
revendications pour le coup qui sont
portées notamment par les syndicats
étudiants sur la précarité étudiante
moi je vois avec la récession économique
la possibilité entre guillemets
d'exploiter les jeunes qui revient en
force donc moi je pense que c'est ça le
principal sujet sur la jeunesse sait
comment est ce qu'on fait pour organiser
un front qui permettent de garantir les
droits étaient un élément dont il faudra
qu'on parle peut-être dans une autre
émission qui est l'apparition de cette
société de livraison avec un fond de
nouveau prolétariat au fait qu'ils sont
ces jeunes gens que l'on voit servir
d'autres jeunes souvent parfois
d'ailleurs sur leur vélo et qui est en
train de brouter tac
le convient d'accélérer ce processus qui
devait se développer sur dix ans et qui
bouleverse l'organisation des sociétés
et même de notre espace et urbain faudra
y revenir parce que c'est très
intéressant et c'est pas absolument
rassurant on en rediscutera c'est promis
la jeunesse de 2020 d'hôtes hadad peu
responsable face à la crise sanitaire en
tout cas sur twitter c'est pas du du
projet qui s'expriment puisque ces
responsables oui à 59% merci d'avoir
suivi alors on n'est peut-être pas
sérieux à 20 ans mais on peut être
généreux et c'est le cas de naomi leroy
28 rennes qui était réalisatrice jusqu'à
présent au figaro et qui nous quittent
pour s'engager justement dans
l'associatif bel et bien triste ce soir
nous aussi mais on est heureux de la
voir s'engager justement dans
l'associatif et deux montres et je
laisse une de le dire un geste généreux
et d'espérance dans ce monde qui comme
disait vincent était assez triste alors
bon courage et à très vite sur figaro
live
[Musique]